foreign
of all the jurisdictions in the world
there is one jurisdiction that is
following what is happening in Ukraine
with special attention every minute
every day and that is none other than
Taiwan an island that seems to be
ticking all the boxes for becoming the
next protagonist of a major
International crisis with the protection
of the United States for more than 70
years Taiwan has lived on the fringes of
the Chinese regime but always with the
latent threat that one day Beijing might
ultimately try to invade the island of
course this hypothesis this possibility
could trigger a conflict that would go
far beyond an armed Clash on a regional
scale it would be the first time since
the Vietnam war that the U.S and China
could potentially face off in a theater
of operations or at least that's the
usual impression one gets If Only from
statements like these so unlike Ukraine
to be clear sir U.S forces U.S men and
women would defend Taiwan in the event
of a Chinese Invasion yes the question
is what could happen if the conflict in
Taiwan finally erupts would China
succeed in taking control of this island
let's get started
[Music]
we have mentioned this a lot of times
taiwan's situation is one of the most
ambiguous in international politics
particularly because the sovereignty of
this island has undergone constant
changes for example and this may
surprise you when the sino-japanese war
of 1895 ended the king Empire ceded the
island in perpetuity to Japan that is
formerly the island of Formosa Taiwan
ceased to be China and so for the next
50 years this island was part of the
Empire of Japan of course Tokyo's defeat
in the second world war again brought
about a turn of events the island once
again became part of the then Republic
of China a country ruled by a military
dictatorship and somewhat aligned with
the United States however when the
revolution of Mao Zedong and Company
succeeded in 1949 the authoritarian
regime of the Republic of China was
exiled to Taiwan since then the island
has been considered by Beijing as a kind
of Rebel Province an island that is
fully autonomous and functions in
practice as a sovereign country but
which however has never been able to
declare its independence
[Music]
firstly because its government
considered itself the legitimate
government of China and later because
Beijing has said Ad nauseam again and
again that any Declaration of
Independence would be considered an act
of war and so it has been molded in this
way a country that over recent decades
has experienced an important economic
technological and also Democratic
success in political and social terms
Taiwan has become the freest territory
on the entire Asian continent the
problem China's appetite is getting
bigger and bigger and if the war in
Ukraine is shown as anything it is that
the territorial claims of the major
powers are once again a feasible
scenario for military conflict the
question is will Taiwan become the new
Ukraine what would a Chinese invasion of
the island look like who would be
involved and what would be the possible
outcomes well stick with me to find out
two starting points
to keep in mind is that in the
hypothesis of a war between the United
States and China in Taiwan both sides
have a completely different view of the
situation this reveals some key points
to keep in mind
[Music]
for Beijing the Taiwan issue is a
strictly domestic one since the island
belongs to the Republic of China and the
Mao Revolution replaced that for the
current Communist Regime the People's
Republic of China from their point of
view Taiwan is a Chinese province with a
de facto degree of special autonomy in
other words XI jinping's government
considers that any military operation
would not be a clash between countries
but an event relating to China's
internal territorial order and keep in
mind that it's this position that
explains beijing's growing belligerence
towards any foreign group meddling on
the island they see it as a kind of
humiliation a feeling that has been
reinforced by years of communist
propaganda China's givo's reunification
with Taiwan for its part however the
United States maintains a commitment to
Taiwan that is not entirely compatible
with this position in the Taiwan
Relations Act enacted on 10th of April
1979. the United States made an
unwavering commitment to this territory
the United States shall make available
to Taiwan such defense articles and
defense services in such quantity as may
be necessary to enable Taiwan to
maintain sufficient self-defense
capabilities Section 3 of the Taiwan
relations act in other words the law
makes it very clear Taiwan must be able
to defend itself against any attempt of
aggression and the United States will be
responsible should this situation occur
in fact there doesn't seem to be much
point in talking about taiwan's defense
except with the US why well look at this
David versus Goliath
the first question we have to answer is
if China eventually does decide to
invade Taiwan which countries would be
involved in the conflict and take note
because this is where the key point of
U.S diplomacy comes into play strategic
ambiguity for years at least officially
Washington has never made it clear
whether or not it would intervene in
that possible conflict and it has not
done so in order to create a double
deterrent on the one hand the latent
threat of U.S intervention could prevent
China from deciding to invade the island
on the other hand the uncertainty also
does not allow Taipei to be overly
aggressive for example by declaring its
independence this is the approach that
according to many analysts has succeeded
in maintaining peace for decades however
things are evolving the Chinese military
is increasingly prepared and if the war
in Ukraine has made anything clear it is
that the strategy of strategic ambiguity
could end up being XI jinping's excuse
to pounce on his prey that is to say if
at any given moment top Chinese
officials thought that the United States
might not come to taiwan's rescue and
mace settle for instance with the
application of sanctions then that might
be the best fuse for unleashing an
invasion this is similar to what
happened with the Russian invasion of
Ukraine Putin and his Entourage felt
that when push came to shove no one
would lift a finger for Kiev and that is
what explains why Joe Biden has
intentionally confused himself not once
not twice but three times making it
clear that the United States would come
to the aid of its Ally so unlike Ukraine
to be clearer sir U.S forces U.S men and
women would defend Taiwan in the event
of a Chinese Invasion yes I don't want
to call war with China I just want to
make China understand that we are not
going to step back we are not going to
change any of our views so are you
saying that that the United States would
come to taiwan's defense in China attack
yes we have a commitment are you willing
to get involved militarily to defend
Taiwan if it comes to that that's the
commitment we made
in other words Washington has not
changed its formal position but the
president wanted to make clear the
position of the White House perhaps it
has a lot to do with the fact that the
advanced semiconductor industry has made
Taiwan an absolutely strategic Enclave
for the United States American companies
American Technology and it doesn't
matter whether we're talking about
artificial intelligence Amazon or the
F-35 they all need chips made by tsmc I
don't know if it's certain but I'm sure
that further supports the resolve of the
United States why is the position of
American power so important well
basically because American power is
taipei's only asset why we'll take a
look
[Music]
the decoration of forces between Taiwan
and the People's Republic of China has
continued to grow over time if the
Chinese armed forces have traditionally
been a poorly equipped poorly trained
and poorly capable Army the situation is
very different today the People's
Republic of China is making an enormous
effort to improve its military
capabilities including the launching of
six new aircraft carriers fifth
generation Fighters new amphibious
capabilities and thousands and thousands
of missiles aimed at Taiwan yes it is
true that Taiwan concentrates its
military spending on protecting a much
smaller territory 36 000 kilometers
Square compared to more than 9 million
but China is directing the bulk of its
military Investments towards Maritime
dominance in the region including the
ability to invade Taiwan in fact the
widening Gap in forces may be the reason
Taiwan has reduced its military effort
over the past few decades the idea is
that a China that is more open to the
world could eliminate any risk of
invasion and that ultimately everything
will depend on the U.S position is
perhaps what explains charts like this
one
begin to change but the truth is that
without International assistance Taiwan
would have a very difficult time
resisting an invasion by China China
launches the most advanced aircraft
carrier on the planet outside the US
China strikes a new military blue with
its new aircraft carrier type 003 Taiwan
highly vulnerable to Chinese Air Attack
leaked documents show troubling details
raise questions about U.S intelligence
agency's ability to detect a pending
Invasion and the Island's capacity to
defend itself now let's suppose that
because of X or Y everything finally
goes wrong things get out of control and
the conflict explodes what could happen
What would be the balance of forces
would any of the contenders clearly
impose themselves well let's take a look
[Music]
War Games
what could happen if War ultimately does
break out in Taiwan it is not such a
far-fetched hypothesis so in Washington
it is something they take very very very
seriously precisely for this reason
several U.S research and defense centers
have carried out simulations to find out
how this possible conflict would develop
in virtually all cases it is taken for
granted that U.S forces would
participate otherwise taiwan's defeat
would be certain well let's take for
example as a starting point the
simulation carried out by the center for
strategic and International Studies a
leading washington-based think tank in
order to carry out this simulation all
possible air and Naval actions were
taken into account as well as all
historical precedents with amphibious
missions from Normandy to Okinawa to the
Falkland Islands the results well take a
look in most scenarios the United States
Taiwan and Japan would succeed in
defeating China's conventional
amphibious Invasion and maintain
taiwan's autonomy however this defense
would come at a high cost the United
States and its allies would lose dozens
of ships hundreds of aircraft and suffer
tens of thousands of casualties just
think the us would have to fight
thousands of miles away against a
Chinese military that would be playing
on home soil through its part taiwan's
economy would be devastated by the
destruction of much of its
infrastructure of course China would
also suffer great losses and the failure
of the operation could end up
destabilizing the Chinese Communist
Party government
the results of this simulation show that
only when Taiwan is left alone would
China succeed in taking control of the
island however even in this scenario
Taiwanese resistance could extend to The
Invasion by 70 days okay I know what
some of you are thinking there you go
again visualpolitik propagandizing for
the Imperial dominance of Uncle Sam well
we're not doing it now nor have we ever
done it before in fact these drills are
anything but encouraging for the United
States in the simulation even the best
case scenario entails extremely
significant losses for the United States
and Japan as well as major economic
repercussions in other words no matter
what the outcome no one would win any
Chinese attempt to invade Taiwan would
be a disaster for all parties but that's
not all
the results of this simulation one of
three more possible risks firstly the
damage caused by cyber attacks could
cause significant economic and social
damage in the United States itself
secondly the damage sustained by U.S
military forces could be difficult to
replace rebuilding capability could take
years while China a country endowed with
greater industrial capacity could take
advantage of such a scenario to turn the
tables it would be something of a
pyrrhic victory for the United States
thirdly countries such as Russia North
Korea and Iran could take advantage of
this distraction and drain on U.S
resources to accelerate their political
agendas in other words even if the
United States could avoid taiwan's
annexation today the potential risks
could be very high
sometimes in war winning is not
everything history teaches us important
lessons in this regard for example in
1919 after the signing of the Treaty of
Versailles French Marshal Ferdinand Fox
expressed his concern about the outcome
of the first world war we've signed a
20-year Armistice the Marshal considered
that despite having won the war France
had been seriously decimated and could
be vulnerable to the German rearmament
in the not too distant future well the
simulation suggests that something very
similar could happen to the United
States
and keep in mind that the consequences
of this issue could become much more
complex even without the outbreak of War
as we all conceive it in January 2022
another Think Tank the center for a new
American Security ran a simulation to
see what might happen to the
semiconductor industry the results were
not optimistic similarly in June 2022
the same Think Tank also conducted a
simulation of how the war might unfold
in this case just before the Invasion
the Dilemma facing Beijing would be
whether to concentrate exclusively on
Taiwan and avoid attacking U.S forces in
the hope that they would stand aside or
on the other hand attack the Americans
to gain military advantage and try to
force a negotiation the Curious Thing is
that according to this simulation in the
end China would choose to attack Taiwan
in parallel to an offensive on nearby
U.S bases and guess what the Chinese
military is known to be training to
attack the U.S Fleet for example as you
can see in these images taken in a
desert in jinjang Province the Chinese
are using targets that recreate
nimitz-class aircraft carrier and other
U.S warships for their military missile
training is this a huge red flag
in fact according to the simulations we
aren't discussing one of China's options
would be to avoid attacking Taiwan with
missiles so as not to seriously damage
its technological industry and instead
detonate a nuclear device in the Pacific
to intimidate the Americans and force
negotiations this would also explain the
recent Rush Xi Jinping seems to be in to
build many more nuclear weapons in other
words if they are really willing to use
such a threat for it to be credible and
have an effect it has to be backed up by
the strongest possible Force China
already surpasses the U.S in
ground-based nuclear offensive
capability China already has more
ground-based nuclear missile launchers
than the United States although it has
not yet surpassed it in total number of
nuclear warheads China likely to have 1
500 nuclear warheads by 2035 Pentagon
and so visualpolitik community in
general the result of most of the
simulations that have been conducted is
that the United States would outperform
China militarily but that yes it would
do say by paying an excessively high
price for not being sufficiently
prepared and you know what this is where
the work of Secretary of State Anthony
blinken and Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin in pushing defense agreements in
the region makes all the sense in the
world it is possible that the best and
perhaps only effective way to deter
China is for the United States to secure
the support of many more contenders
Japan South Korea Australia United
Kingdom and so on and so forth in other
words that in this case the US card
alone may no longer be enough of a
deterrent for China and this leads
directly to another question what have
we learned and what have we not learned
from the Ukrainian experience
keeves non-lesson and insufficient
victory
one problem with taiwan's defense is
that trying to replicate what has been
done in Ukraine to prevent foreign
intervention may not be feasible the
geographical situation is completely
different I think you'll be able to see
the differences perfectly on these maps
in the Ukrainian War both the United
States and the other NATO allies have
sent huge quantities of equipment and
supplies by land something that would be
impossible in Taiwan because of its
Island status in this case China could
isolate the island for weeks or even
months in fact on 8th of April for at
least three days the Chinese military
rehearsed how to conduct a total
encirclement of Taiwan to cut off any
possibility of the United States being
able to resupply local self-defense
forces it's a strategy that is
reinforced by things like this check it
out current procurement and acquisition
plans reveal that in 10 years the United
States will not have significantly more
forces to deploy in the region than it
has now the U.S Navy is modernizing but
it will not have its planned Fleet of
between 450 and 500 ships until 2045 a
fleet size that China will have in just
10 years thus any attempts to defend
Taiwan has to start with the island
being prepared to repel an invasion at
any time including having all the
ammunition and supplies necessary to
resist
from its part the United States must
have the capability to rapidly deploy
troops and equipment in or around Taiwan
and you know what all of what we're
seeing is why Taiwan is becoming the
number one priority for security and
defense officials not only in their own
government but also in the U.S Congress
U.S war game against Taiwan shows need
for decisive action to increase Armament
a U.S congressional war game simulating
a Chinese invasion of Taiwan showed the
need to arm the island to the teeth the
U.S should increase long-range missile
production and companies should prepare
for The Economic Consequences but of all
this of the possible plan to try to
defend itself against China we have
already covered in several videos here
on visualpolitik so I'll leave you the
links in the description visualpolitik
viewers the war in Ukraine has shown us
two things that the unthinkable is
perfectly possible and that the times of
great military clashes have not yet been
laid to rest in the history books the
U.S objective is to seek ways to
preserve taiwan's Independence and in
general the military and economic
superiority of free country over any
autocracy in the world but in order to
achieve this it may be absolutely
indispensable to enlist strong support
and allies the question is can taiwan's
de facto Independence really be
safeguarded will China be willing to
take up arms will the United States
succeed in building a grand Coalition of
free countries willing to defend
taiwan's Freedom leave your answers in
the comments and let's open a debate and
now if you found this video interesting
don't forget to hit the like button and
subscribe to visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so all the best see
you next time
foreign